ames have been released in britain in
greece in india and spain and it seems
to it seems to have caused the storm
everyone we hope that it will help to
public awareness first of all and mainly
public awareness of the Royal Air tax
evasion or of offshore banking of what
is the the part of the finance this
already out of control so offshore
banking is out of control and you think
that's what the data that you took from
hsbc it shows this clearly exactly
exactly it's showing us exactly that is
out of control and that the regulation
they want to say I've changed the rules
are not done the right way and we still
have the proofs in front of us that why
public awareness is the most important
is that why you did it is that why you
took the data that that that work that
were that what we did thanks to
journalists thankful or investigators
that I like that many things before to
you is this what you want it to happen
because you want this to get out so
those you wanted a secure get out of
course I want the bad i want my my bank
let's say the financial system to get
back to what I knew it was years ago